the last time I spoke to you you were
going to direct the crow three the
sequel to The Crow now what happened
with this well I wasted two good years
of my life on that right and it was like
every Monday morning they would look at
the box office grosses and they'd go and
when private parts is number one they
were like is there any way when we get
Howard in the movie yeah and then like
the next weekend Starship Troopers was
the number one so they're like how do we
work giant bugs into the movie and every
weekend it would change until finally I
was like I Know What You Did Last Summer
was big right and they wanted to make an
all-teen cast right I was like this is
absurd and I just was like so that's it
you quit well then they turned then they
then it became this thing that now it's
it's come up again they're they're
sending out press releases on it and I
haven't talked to anyone over there in a
year that's like we want to take his
script and turn it into a different
movie hmm and I was just like so you
wrote the script for Crow three
but you don't know what's gonna you're
not gonna direct it no no well that's a
shame I was looking forward to that what
happened was after the second movie was
a total stiff yeah they got all ballsy I
think like oh we'll make this insane
movie because it doesn't matter anymore
right so I wrote this crazy you know
more hardcore script right we made the
crow older and nastier and I wanted to
get like The Good the Bad and the Ugly
or something and they're like yeah
that's that'll be badass and then about
a year and a half into it they're like
why don't we get Skeet Ulrich and make
it a friendly teen Crow yeah I was like
yeah well same thing same thing I
personally could see Bon Jovi as the
crow they did they wanted Bon Jovi to be
the crow yep well I'm down with that and
then when that came out that was for the
second movie they actually went to it
yeah I'd like to be the crow why not
you're telling me ringing tomorrow you
could be in that black glycra outfit
yeah I got the look for it so who would
you like to have seen be the crow
I wanted to get somebody like Scott
Glenn Scott Glenn like an old really
running that's great guy his head looks
right skull